you got a lot of Zed's flying around in
your complex numbers right now I'm not a
huge fan of writing like this however
when you're in an exam we know you're
rushing I brush as well
your legibility just kind of die badly
you're writing sort of went down a bad
way okay and mine would too okay
however therefore especially when you've
got like dead squids around and let's
face it you've always gotten ten squids
around okay you have to do something
don't tell me that's a Zed or not - okay
Zed's look like two's on a good day
on a bad day like when you're doing exam
and you're in a hurry it just it's a
mess okay I only got you the marks
because I knew what you were writing but
there's no guarantees about your happen
so that's why I put my - to my Zed
that's pretty unambiguous okay even if
you're in a hurry anyway
now what we were required to prove you
need to use the masculine to prove this
now how are we going to do it a lot of
you are still in that bad habit of when
you have something to prove you go
through the left-hand side and you do
something to it and then you're gonna
right-hand side and you do something to
it and you sort of give them to look
close enough and then you say fine I'm
finished okay but that is not what you
are required to prove you are quite
clear that one of them is equal to the
other if you can do it from both sides
you can do it from one side to the other
you just need to take those steps and
reverse it right just present it
properly over and over again as I was
marking throughout this paper the the
drum it kept on being bait was the
mathematical abilities they're the
communication of the presentation are
not okay and you will get killed in the
HSC for that they'll just say zero it's
not presented properly right it doesn't
matter how much I understand you
actually had there if you can't
translate it onto the page so he's the
way I would do it I'd say he's the left
hand side you go with the left because
they've told you to use them wasps right
so if you don't use it you get zero
right if they if they what's the if they
stipulate a method you have to use it
okay so you just do the expansion here
okay now at this point this is where you
use the theorem right but wow we're
slopey again I'm just you're gonna get
sick of me saying it okay but present
your answer clearly if someone giving a
speech in English right if you're giving
a speech in English and the quotes are
great and the connections are great and
the thesis is perfect and the whole time
through a little worried and mumbled
like that that's kind of the equivalent
of what we were doing mathematically
right you're presenting very clearly
when you do your powers here right and
you translate it in you should write up
with your brackets there right it don't
need something right the computer can
get away with it because it's perfectly
legible every time when you guys are
ready to join the rest of us
you cannot write I saw some people
writing this sign when is it like that
what is that I take it you mean this
right but Wow and the number of
variations I saw on that like like this
I think I saw minus one times this it's
what what is this exactly okay I'll be
careful
I mean you don't really need to write
that it's a bit excessive okay but still
it's about trying to make your reasoning
clear so you've got this here yeah
that's one and then you get your other
one with your negative power okay now do
you have to say by Tomas theorem
probably don't have to but what are we
trying to do here right are we trying to
write the minimum or are we trying to
communicate as clearly as possible right
so you should have on your crunches I
didn't deduct it there right just all
right I spell it wrong yeah somebody um
you should say it you should say it just
like Pythagoras if we quit my beggar's
chicoy this right now from there again
in exactly the same way you went to the
next line but you said nothing as to why
okay what is the next line what truth
what property are going are you going to
use about causal sign which will let you
get to what you try to prove what's the
property you're going to do something
with these minus signs right you're
gonna say clothes anything up five side
Envy doc what happens to this it just
becomes cause it beer right but why why
because it's an even function right so
therefore f of minus X is the same as
that vets in the same way you're gonna
do a trick with this - but why because
it's an odd function right but I don't
know if anyone actually said that you're
just expecting the market to know that
that's what you meant
okay now here's the thing right we pay
extra attention to what's going on here
because you already know what the answer
is right someone who doesn't know what
they're doing
can see at this point I have to get rid
of my signs right and this cause which
is negative it'll have to become
positive or somehow right so you don't
need to understand what's going on to
write down these lines you need to
provide the reasons to show that you do
understand what's going on okay
communicate it please I was pretty
gracious on you son because there's the
first assessment that walking for you
okay but we need to tie this up pretty
bad and that's where you get the result